[Music]
what I'm going to talk today about is
best practices on migrating to cloud
spanner and I'm Robert Kubis I'm the
lead advocate for the storage and
database system for the Google cloud
platform you can find me on Twitter
under the name at Aussie Hosty if you
like to chat with me or send me feedback
or anything first of all I want to point
out that we have a Dory for this session
I've already one question was put on
there so please feel free to put
questions on there and we will try to
answer them throughout the conference so
please check back if you've asked the
question and you will answer them there
all right
I might actually also pick one or two
questions if I have time at the end from
the dory
you'll see so before I start and go and
dive into I would like to like
understand what my audience is so who of
you here has already played with cloud
spanner okay
quite a bit who is in production with
cloud spanner all right there of you all
right cool
for all the others thank you for for
joining definitely and everybody thank
you for joining this session is actually
aimed as like in-between so I not gonna
talk about like the basics of what
spanner is but I will mention here and
there if it helps for the understanding
so here are the things that are gonna
cover today and so for the ones that are
in production it might be that a lot of
the things that I talked about today are
things that you already know and there
might even may be nothing new maybe
there is something new so please don't
let be that's disappointed going out of
this talk I want to set the expectations
right in the beginning so feel free if
you think like this is maybe not what
you were looking for I don't like hold
it to you if you look for a different
session so today we're gonna go through
pretty much three stages first I want to
talk about if you blend to move
to spanner primarily if you're coming
from another for instance relational
database system or a Noah scale database
system so what are the difference is of
like traditional database systems trade
the traditional RDBMS to clouds banner
and what to look out for number two I
will talk about the move the move of
your data so how do you get data quickly
into cloud spanner and how would you
design the system where you actually
have to move from one database and you
want to have your application either
running throughout the transition or
where you can actually accommodate some
downtime and how you would do that and
number three is I'm looking a little bit
in a couple of like monitoring
inspection optimizing aspects so this
will mostly focus on the things that we
see very very often in terms of what
customers are reporting to us where they
are having challenges to get the best
performance out of cloud spanner and
last but not least I will mention a
couple of very interesting sessions that
are actually still coming up which I
encourage you to go to all right so one
slide what is cloud spanner so we say
it's the best of two worlds of the
relational semantics and having
horizontal scale so there's a lot of
technology going on underneath sloughed
spanner which makes that possible
traditionally if you look at like
horizontally scaling databases there are
two basically flavors either you go and
like sacrifice some of the relational
semantics and with this the consistency
constraints or you might end up like
with a lot of click conflict resolution
very like maybe a system that you have
to like particular co-locate to get a
good performance out of it because of
the communication that is necessary to
ensure the strong consistency now under
cloud spanner there is a system called
true time which allows us to remove some
of the communication necessary to ensure
strong consistency so let's dive into
the planning aspect of it so if you look
at like traditional database the digital
relational databases and that is usually
like a single host system right so they
are vertical
scalable if you need more power you put
more CPUs and you put more main memory
in that but at some point there is the
ceiling what you can scale vertically
now in this single horse system like
over the last 40 50 years by now there
have a lot of like cool features
developed but which are specifically
tailored for a single horse system and
which are detrimental to a system which
you distribute horizontally over modern
machines even sones and regions so some
of them I mentioned and here so if you
look at traditional databases you have
things like value constrained so you can
check you can do foreign keys constrains
and with this referential integrity you
have sequences right which you can use
for your for your primary key for
instance and it's nothing bad to use
them it's actually example and sometimes
really helpful to use these sequences in
single horse systems you have
possibilities for like user-defined
functions to do verification to do type
conversion things like that you have
stored procedures where you can put
business logic in and you have triggers
where you can basically trigger certain
processes processes asynchronously over
multiple tables or even synchronously if
you want to and then also a feature
which is very common in traditional
databases is that you have very fine
train'll or permission systems right so
most databases support formation systems
on databases on tables and then there
like a few that go down to row or even
cell level permission systems in your
database now how does this compare to
cloud spanner number one you have no
sequences so the way that cloud spanner
is storing data is we basically order
the table alpha numerically by the
primary key and then we partition or we
split this table up and we move this
like splits through different hosts to
be responsible for these splits actually
it's not one whole services responsible
it's app access group that is
responsible so it's three machines
usually three machines that are
responsible for one split which is
basically a part of
table now since we're ordering them
alpha numerically by the primary key if
you would use a sequence as a primary
key you can imagine that like new data
would always be like appended at the end
so it always goes to the same split and
by having like only one split be
responsible for all the load you run
into hot spotting because like only one
one paksas group is responsible for that
one split and so the boundaries of your
scale abilities are basically what you
can put in terms of load onto this split
and these machines that are working on
that we have also not things like
foreign key constraints because they can
be really expensive if you if you need
to do this verification of referential
integrity across multiple splits maybe
even across multiple regions so we have
something which is kind of a foreign key
constraint - - which we call interleaved
tables so you can actually interleave a
table into another table because they
are living on the same split we can
actually do this referential integrity
there and we can do things like the lead
on cascade and stuff like that another
thing that we don't currently support
and cloud spanner are things like
triggers stored procedures and
user-defined functions all these things
have to basically move up into your
application layer to have the same
functionality for your application if
you want to move from a traditional
database system to clouds better and
then the next thing is the user
permission systems that we support on
cloudspinners currently on on the
database level so you can create a
service account and can give like the
database write and read levels but you
can't go any lower than that so all the
user control that you have or the access
control that you want to support again
needs to move into your application
layer there are a couple of other things
to mention so if you look for instance
at the data type set cloud spanner
supports there's like a good variety of
later of data types but we hear loud and
clear and we are looking into that and
working on it to support a numeric tie
especially if a numeric type for
financial applications or select
scientific applications where you need a
lot of accuracy and precision a numeric
type is basically something what you
want to have in your database natively
supported currently we don't support it
so our advice was if you move from a
system which is reports a numeric type
to cloud spanner to store these things
in string float and integer will not
give you enough precision unless you are
basically distributing your numerix
across multiple integers or multiple
floats again this also is in line with
the know sequences if you look at the
primary keys to enable the distribution
to enable the the horizontal scale you
want to have very well distributed
primary keys so if you come from like a
my scalp office or any of like the
larger third-party databases that are
out there and you're using something
like a sequence or you're using a like
continuous generated key for your
primary keys you need to basically
modify that so use something like you
Aidid version 4 or prefix your your key
of something that is well distributed
another important thing to look at in
cloud spanner is that like advanced
structures like indexes for inserts are
actually like mapped back to basic
structures in cloud spanner so indexes
are just normal tables in our back-end
fixiki which you don't see as such you
see them as indexes but we are actually
handling handling them as tables and
this is important here if you look at
traditional databases and you look at
indexes how they work you basically
build up like usually like a hash map or
something where you can go do an index
scan and if you find your your key or
what you're looking for and you want to
map the the row against it like yet some
other data out of your base table for
that linked index lookup you basically
just do a jump either in memory or you
know where it is located on disk and you
map that into your memory and then
basically can
we access the data for off your base
table now since data is distributed in
cloud spanner we don't have these
advantages on that level for lookups you
can't just like go and go to a different
memory location on a different host to
do the lookup of the base table data for
a certain row so what actually happens
is you do the index lookup it's just a
table basically and then if you don't
have the data in your index that you
actually want to access with your query
you do have to do a back draw into the
base table and a back drawing in a
distributed system can be very expensive
so be aware of this that if you create
indexes and you want to actually have
some that are providing you the data
that qualifies for your query there are
capabilities to store that data with the
index so it's basically stored in the
same table and so you do not need to do
the back transfer all right so what are
the workloads like four of them which
are fitting well onto a cloud spanner so
one of them is like if you have already
charted a relational database system you
probably already like in the weeds of
like managed this is looking at like how
you shard like maybe you do have two
repartition things stuff like that so
it's usually a lot of work to do these
charted systems but because you have a
shorted systems many of the things that
I mentioned earlier of like UDF's or
stored procedures you might already not
using anymore because they don't work
well in in this charted system so you
might have gotten rid of these things
already in your in your database layer
and have moved them re to the
application layer so if that is the case
the transition and my creation the move
to cloud spanner might be much much
easier for you another thing is if you
are at the edge of scalability I
mentioned if you like at the edge of
vertical scalability and you want to
basically consider to move into a no SQL
world because you need the horizontal
scale that is also a good use case where
you can look into cloud spanner you keep
the relational semantics but you get the
horizontal scale on top of it
third one is a manageability and high
availability so if you have a system
where you run for instance your master
and then multiple failover systems
because you need to be high available in
case of there's any like data corruption
or machine fault or anything and you
fail over to a different machine you
usually get some some time like offline
time during that process to failover and
to catch up on locks and things like
that so this is a case also which is
very good case for using cloud spanner
because it's distributed by default it's
high available by default you have
regional instances with four nines of
availability and the multi region
instance is four five nine of
availability and if the five nines of
availability comes the multi region
capability of cloud spanner so we have
configurations where your data lives in
multiple regions that we support as
Google Cloud region's and the
responsibility for data elements is
basically moved between these two
regions and then if one region fails all
the responsibility for that data moves
to the other region and your data like
your database lives on is still
accessible from like that other region
all right so what are things that are
don't fit well and flowered spinner so
if you are heavily invested with stored
procedures UDF things like that into
your traditional database system and you
want to basically pick it up and drop it
onto clouds better you won't be happy
there will be a lot of challenges it
might actually like not even work for
for various reasons so lift and shift is
not really a thing for cloud spanner it
is a lift andrey platform reapplication
another thing is if you use in your
application like ORM things like that
you're looking and be investing into RM
support but at the moment we don't have
like a lot of ORM support so if you look
into compatibility of like what you have
on traditional database systems in terms
of library that is just not in that
state yet for for cloud spanner
and then if you look into applications
where you need really really low latency
is like single-digit milliseconds or
even down to the Nano and micro seconds
that's also not an application for cloud
spanner because of the nature that we
focus on high availability and
manageability and so the way that cloud
spanner is build under needs to have the
durability of your data just doesn't
allow for the very low single-digit
millisecond latency so another thing
that you don't want to do with cloud
spanner which I added there on the
fourth point is cloud spinner is not an
OLAP database so if you do like
heavyweight analytical queries you will
run into problems you will it will be
painful and you won't be happy with it
so for that I encourage everybody to
look into a bigquery or you can pick
table if you have something that you
need a little bit more real-time
analytics look into these two storage
systems that we have available as well
to help you with your analytical needs
all right so just like kind of a summary
what are the things that you want to
look at if you do your schema migration
from it like your old application on a
traditional database system to cloud
spanner so if you have monitor knee
crease prefix them use well distributed
keys and use interleaving carefully
right so as mentioned in the leaf tables
are ending up in the same split as the
parent row so if you have a lot of load
on an interleaved table for one row for
of your parent table you basically go to
one split and so you are your deign and
danger of hot spotting to that split in
terms of indexes again what we see a lot
is that customers are basically looking
at the schema they fixing their primary
keys they're happy everything is great
and then we create an index on the
updated row or on the insert row or
insert time row so as mentioned like an
index is also a table and if you create
an index on the monotonic field you run
into the exact same problems right so
beware of this like that index has
behaved the same as your tables and you
need to pay attention to what you use as
your primary key for your tables as well
as for your indexes and then if you have
things like like an example is a social
network why do we have a really hot key
like there's one popular person which
like everybody wants to know something
about it consider like replicating and
duplicating that key and build the logic
around that into your into your
application to make sure that it's still
strong consistent updated across all
your replicas all right so another thing
which we see very caught works very
common is that that what we what it's
very common what you see is that there
are like ten tables created during
runtime or anything kind of like schema
changes like very often done like
there's like new applications are
deployed very frequently and with every
application deployment there is a schema
or change so you have to be careful with
schema changes and cloudspinner supports
or nine schema changes so you don't have
any downtime that we experienced if you
do a schema change but we keep schemas
around for around an hour and the reason
is you can actually travel back in time
with cloud spanner and its so called
time bounded reads which are used for
like backups for instance but also if
you want to use a little bit less locks
for and like let's let contention you
can do time bounded reads or time pouted
queries so be aware of that that if you
do a lot of schema changes that they
basically stack up and we keep them all
memory and that puts a lot of memory
pressure on our system so use them
wisely and use them sparsely try to
aggregate your schema changes as
mentioned they're like the schema
changes are serialize that they put on a
stack and and rolled out after each
other and they are transactional so we
basically do all the schema changes in
the background and then once the schema
the new schema is all ready we flip it
over with a transaction and every any
transaction
that are in flight which would span two
versions of the schema we basically just
aborted and rerun that transactions and
then four schema changes if you have new
indexes that you create these indexes
can be very like can take for like days
even if you backfill the index from very
large tables so beware of that as well
all right so with all the things all the
constraints and all the challenges that
cloud spanner has if you move onto
clouds better there are some good things
about it there actually a lot of good
things like I am working on cloud
spanner for two and a half years now
like it is one of definitely one of my
favorite products a lot of fun playing
with it benefit given I don't have to
pay out of my pocket for it but it's a
lot of fun to play with it so what do
you get actually if you move on the
cloud spanner you get a fully managed
system so that is like important not to
forget right so you don't need to think
do any upgrades you don't have to down
times you don't have like don't have
down times in within the SLA you don't
have any software patching that you have
to do you don't have to do any recording
all this is done for you we do the load
balancing we do the optimizations of the
splits and things like that behind the
scenes based on your traffic patterns
and really important is you get strong
consistency across a horizontally
distributed system right so through
asset capabilities and strong
consistence which is the highest highest
guarantee of strong consistence that you
have out there so we don't we don't
believe in choosing your consistency
level we just give you the highest all
right so what to consider this is
basically the plane in planning fat face
right so these are the things that you
have to consider is the application that
you're running right now is that is it
suitable to move how much you have to
invest in terms of work what work do I
have to invest in terms of like schema
changes application changes things like
that now if you decide and say like yes
there are all these benefits that come
with it and I want to move on to cloud
spanner here are a couple of ideas how
to approach this so number one
might be sound like very simplistic but
I still want to put it out here the
easiest way to move your application to
cloud spanner is to bundle all your
database access code into one module all
right so with that you can do a lot of
amazing things you can basically isolate
the testing for that module you can
optimize around that module like in
terms of latency in terms of contention
in terms of ACLs that you can implement
in this model so it makes it much easier
if you if you have the possibility in
your application to isolate the DB
access code and move that all into one
module so that it makes the transition
from your old system to the new system
much more straightforward so now how
would you do that in terms of like
getting your data over one of
possibility is to use Cloud dataflow or
like in like use a backup that you can
use on MySQL PostgreSQL they can have
different formats if it is CSV if is
Avro if it's PUC hey it's up to you and
then you move that basically into cloud
storage into a cloud storage bucket and
then from there you use the recommended
way is to use loud data flow to load
this data into Cloud spanner and I gonna
show a little bit please switch in a
second through my laptop if I remember
of my password oh okay all right let's
do caffeine which I would need as well
so what I want to show here is if you
want to get started with data flow to
load data into your cloud spanner
instance we have actually some data flow
templates available for you that you can
look into and basically take as an
inspiration or even modify it in a way
as you want so on github on the Google
cloud platform organization you find
data flow templates and as you can see
here we have a bunch of templates which
allow you to
basically export into into for instance
of Rosie's video text files and then
also note from GCSE text into cloud
spanner or from yeah into a cloud
spanner so this is a good place to start
and these are actually the templates
that we are also using for our self
manage back up that you have available
so I want to show that really quickly so
what is possible is actually here I have
a bunch of my instances that are running
right now I have done or your restores I
going to show that in a second
but basically what you can do is you can
go on to a database click the export
button select a bucket where you want to
export it so I have here my ticket shop
backups I can select this go all through
this select the database you want to
support select the region the region you
want to select the region where that
instance is actually living and it shows
you which one is recommended confirm all
the changes and then you do the export
for this example like for this database
it has around 120 gigabytes of data
it took about 20 minutes to export this
data so let me show like how that looks
like when I actually get that back and
it doesn't show me unfortunately
so I gonna show right here I hope it's
possible to show that let's go to data
flow so here you see the export job that
we did and it's basically creating all
this behind the scenes you saw here it
showed right now like 1 hour and 40 but
that is actually not the actual time the
wall time that it took it is the time
the aggregated time through all the
instances that were use so if you look
at the elapsed time we have that here on
the right which shows 22 minutes for
doing that backup of around at set like
hundred and eight gigabytes now if you
go into the import again I can show the
dialog we in a second it's very easy you
pick basically the folder where you
exported it to and then it creates
although it creates the database schema
automatically and then loads into this
data now some might spot there is a
queen line over here and the blue line
over here and they don't match up which
is usually not a good sign and that is
also the reason why we see here it took
an hour to restore that data again this
can be improved a lot by having
sufficient quota for your data flow jobs
so as you can see here I didn't have a
sufficient border so add around 25
workers
I was maxed out on my quota and the
green line is actually suggested scaling
of the data flow job in terms of nodes
that are helping or workers that are
helping loading this data so if I would
have had more quota this restored job
would have gone much faster but this is
again it's not and something that is
automated in the background from for us
in terms of like how do you schedule you
have to schedule your own backups and
restores if you want to use this so let
me go back really quick so how would
that look like if you have like one
stinson insta an instance running here
you would go to your bucket take your
truck backups
select folder say for instance let's say
demo is your one select the region
confirm import and then it basically
again creates this data flow job you see
here already like the schema is created
and in a second it should come up that
we have the state of load job you can go
here look at it and it grades at all
behind the scenes and I don't need to do
anything more alright let's switch back
to the slides please alright so for if
you don't want to use the the data flow
job and to load your data into cloud
spanner you want to run your own import
into cloud spanner there are a couple of
best practices that you want to look at
number one what we see a lot is you
create a new instance you create a new
database and then you
throw all the load basically against the
database what you will see is that in
the beginning it'll take a while to
actually catch up and scale nicely and
the reason for this is to create your
new instance and new database with your
schema all your tables are empty and all
your tables have exactly one split so up
to the point that we actually have a
nice splitting of the tables which can
accommodate the load you will see
basically not the not your best possible
performance so if you actually want to
move over your life data your production
data in a really quick manner from your
old system to the new system
what you recommend is that you create
your database the schema and then load
it with generated data or with some like
maybe you can use a backup to preload
that that database then delete all the
data and then load the actual data that
you want to leave a load into there the
reason is like with pre loading your
database you basically preforming all
the splits and that enables it to much
to pick go much faster when you actually
need the higher performance the second
thing is group and batch multiple rows
together in a transaction the optimal
size between one and ten megabytes and
we have a limitation of 20 Stowers and
imitation this is a hard limitation we
won't remove that for the forces for the
foreseeable future so you have to stay
in this twenty thousand mutations range
what is a mutation mutation is any cell
change that you have in in your tables
so imagine you have a table with five
columns and then you have an internal
and two let's say three primary keys and
then you have another index which is
using the primary keys just in a
different order and let's say also for
all the three primary keys you have
actually for Eddie a row that you insert
into that base table you have eight
mutations five are coming from your base
table and three are coming from the
index table so I have that in mind like
if you have a lot of indexes in there
and you want to load a lot of data into
your table you might run quickly into
the 20,000
limitation then if you do the batching
and loading into a cloud spanner and
this might sound counterintuitive but
actually order your data that you want
to load into cloud spanner by primary
key and then split it up into distinct
ranges and then send these distinct
ranges to to cloud spanner that gives
you the best throughput to load into
cloud spanner and then of course scale
out your import processes all right so
two types of like migrations that you
can do number one course is the doing an
application migration with with a
downtime so here basically you have your
application talking to your original DB
you do all the export and import into
cloud spanner you have like you have
pretty new application ready and so you
turn your application down then you do
the backup and restore into cloud
spanner and then you turn the new
application on and let the new
applications speak to cloud spanner
simple but it is downtime now if it's a
little bit more complicated if you will
actually want to have a system that runs
without downtime and you want to have an
online migration then you do like all
the China schema adoption as well you
have you deploy your new application
basically which have both versions can
speak to the old end into the new M
database you do an export which
basically the preload while your
application still uses the original to
be as the original source of truth and
then you implement basically a dataflow
job for instance which to us the change
data capturing from your original
database into cloud spanner and as soon
as they basically catch up and they are
in sync you can flip the switch and let
your application talk to it now it's
better and hit the launch button and
have a launch party and cross the
fingers that everything works fine so in
in summary isolate DB code do the scheme
updates upfront with the best practices
that I mentioned move your business
logic to their application run your old
and new data
the databases in parallel if you want to
do the online and then basically do is a
switch or war and test that priests
multiple times before you do it actually
on your customers alright so that
concludes section one planning section
to how you would officially move your
data to the cloud spanner and the third
one is monitoring inspecting and
optimizing so I have a couple of demos
that I show here of course again I could
only pick very specific ones I would
love to like pick like and do an entire
session only about the index
modifications and optimizations but I
probably would lose 80% of the of the
room and that I want to avoid so I have
actually concentrated on something
simple so I want to set the stage first
so this is the stage that I want to set
so this is a schema it's fairly
straightforward
I use the schema to design the schema
for the 2017 launch keynote demo for
cloud spanner so you can see we reuse
things sometimes I love to reuse schema
it allows me to do a couple of really
nice demos so what we have here is what
I create as a demo application is a like
a simulated ticket shop and that ticket
shop basically uses a global global
distributed multi-regional global
spanner instance and you can buy tickets
in a strong consistent manner from all
over the world the cool thing here is
I'm not gonna sell a ticket twice which
happens for some airlines or hurt and
other places which is not necessarily
the best thing to have for your customer
and they are standing in front of the
airplane door and you are not allowed in
because their plane is full right so a
strong consistent system here can help
greatly if you actually can sell the
tickets exactly that you want now some
might walk up to me afterwards to say
like they do that on purpose
I know they do that on purpose because
there are a lot of people that don't
show up now what I do I want to show
like I have three tables that we're
going to look at a little bit more in
detail I have my venue table so I have
showers
venues all over the world that I
generated artificially I have a seating
category looks much better on this
display and then on this I have the
seating category there which basically
tells me like it's just a general
seating it's a VIP seating is it long is
it a saloon do you get dinner if it's
something like that and then I have the
actual tickets so the tickets basically
are the tickets and in that case I've
pre created these tickets so that I just
need to flip some bits if I want to sell
a ticket so the cardinalities in these
tables are in my venue table I have a
thousand venues in my sitting categories
I have like two thousand six hundred
fifty five seating categories so roughly
2.6 eating categories per venue and
that's an average there are some venues
which only have one sitting category
there are others which have five and
then I have my tickets if I can count
correctly this is about twenty thousand
tickets that I have in my database now
what I want to show is I want to
basically do optimization of an index so
what I'm going to show first is I'm
going to show a query that I have run
which I started actually before I
started this talk and so you can see I
want to see like to explain the query I
want to know how many tickets are
available in the buildin old club which
is my venue name so to find out I
basically have to go to my venue join it
with my seeding category join it with
the ticket table and then do the Select
and the ones that are ephemeral over
here in this room with SQL they cringe
probably right now the way that I've
written this query and I've written that
on purpose
this way so basically what you see here
is I'm doing join from my seeding
category on to the ticket table and then
on to the venue so now I could make that
even worse if I would switch and say
like I want to join from my ticker table
to my seeding category and then to the
venue
my career wouldn't actually finish it
times out I test it trust me it times
out and so I did the second worst option
here I basically take my seat in
Category join my ticket and join the
venue the problem that we have here is I
have a pretty big cardinality table that
I joined basically in the beginning and
the larger Cadillac the smaller
cardinality table towards the end as you
can see here this took four minutes to
to basically finish and I have a couple
of things that are actually pretty nice
here so you see like the row scanned how
much CPU time I'm using it shows you
basically the query plan here that you
can see okay I'm doing in table scan on
the venue then I'm using an index on the
seating category which is all right good
I'm using an index on my ticket table
which is good but I'm still going
through all my tickets so in the end
it's it's fairly slow so I want to show
the power of actually improving just by
reordering the way that you are joining
your table tables together so in this
case I'm doing the better thing so
always like as a rule of thumb join the
spikes begin with the smallest
cardinality table if you do joins all
right so here I'm starting with my venue
table and then drawing the seating
category and then join the ticket tickle
table on it so now if we run it we're
gonna see it will take still a little
bit while if the demo gods are with me
and it will show in a in a second I
think it should be around 25 seconds so
but basically you see here that's still
not great right it's only as how is in
venues this should go much faster what
is happening here and Oh 15 seconds that
is awesome
so from we went down from 240 seconds to
15 seconds just by reordering the joints
it so think about that if you run into
like problems into issues into like
latency and query times issues look at
like what are the cardinalities of your
tables we know
create optimizer does that automatically
we don't have the greatest optimizer yet
we were working on it but so there's is
still a little bit of manual labor
involved here if you want to get a good
create times now I'm gonna take this as
you can see we are still like scanning
twenty million rows here which is very
still way too much it takes us fifteen
seconds to actually do this so what I
did is I hope this is the right one what
I did actually I looked at the ticket
table and saw like a que can I actually
create an index which helps me in this
so I created an index which is on the
category ID because I want to join with
my seating category and and then I have
the ticket ID so I can draw in the
ticket table onto it and then you see
something else and in the bottom right
so I have some more data actually in the
bottom and so what I can do in this
index is I can actually the Flair like
what I want to index on and then I can
attach data to it so this is a storing
clause that I mentioned earlier so if we
show the DDL you can see here you
basically have the storing clause and
that allows you to basically attach some
data to your primary key in this index
and that is very helpful now my some
might ask like why do I do it in storing
and not into the primary key there there
can be multiple reasons number one is
you change actually the ordering of your
index if you put them into into the
primary key of the index columns so that
is something to consider there are some
other things that are behind the scenes
which are considered basically if they
are index columns versus stored columns
so now let's have a look at the query
how it runs here and as we can see it
runs now in 100 milliseconds gives me
the same data back there's a sixteen
hundred and fifty seats in my rollin old
Club and if we look at like how many
rows were actually scanned there were
only 16 52 scans we run rescan two rows
so much we still have potential for
improvement here but as you can see we
went down from 20 million rows and 240
seconds and I didn't even the vert do
the worst kind of query down to
milliseconds by using creating the right
indices and using the right draw in
order for your queries all right so
let's switch back to the slides
okay so there's also like I want to
repeat again like on the indexes because
it's something that is often forgotten
if you do have indexes and use the
storing clause you basically avoid with
the storing clause to do a back drawing
against the base table all right so if
you if you have a query it so it's
queries where you do a select star of
something really bad really bad so don't
do a select star we really like focus on
these like in your select what columns
you really need and then if if you
expect or hope and index to be used for
your queries make sure that the index
has all the columns that you need for
your query all right so as soon as there
is one column not available you it
basically is you create the back join to
the base table numbers another thing
that we see often is in an index where
you define an index and then you use a
sub sub primary key or some of sub-index
columns but you don't use the prefix so
let's say you do have a primary key ABC
and you index on
BCA and then you do a query on C right
if it basically can't use your index you
have to basically go back to your table
and do a table scan so make sure that
you in your queries
you use the same prefix of index columns
for both all right and then terms of
like locks in terms of complex
transactions make sure that you the
locks are on range and column level so
make sure that you
trick that to the actually only used and
needed data so if you doing like large
range you lock the entire table right so
make sure that the ranges are small and
your complex transactions and the way to
do that is actually to do a query first
to get like IDs or like get like primary
key ranges for the things where you want
to actually write data to and then do
that in your readwrite transaction to
really restrict that and also to get the
benefit of caching make sure you use
something like bounded parameters all
right another thing that is helpful to
understand is to see like how it
transactions and locking is working in
in cloud spanner so I want to dive into
two types of transaction that cloud
spanner is supporting or like yeah that
is supporting number one is the single
split right for a finger split right the
advantage here is what we have if you do
actually apply it right you we can
actually sequence your rights and we can
share the right lock on that split and
that is really powerful we basically
just use through time which is our
global walk like clock time that we use
in cloud spanner to sequence your
transaction and we still have strong
consistency and don't lock on your on
your rights so how does it work here you
see here we have the spanner front end
it's the API fronted that you like
client talks to that does so in lookup
and the split lookup on where the split
lives this is usually very heavily
cached so the second time that has come
comes in the front and it will respond
to that already so this like happens
very rarely actually the first two lines
that you see there then we send the
commit requests we acquire a write lock
we assign it to time times them we are
waiting out at that time till that like
upper bound has passed basically and
during that time we send a persist
request to the replicas which are also
responsible for that split as soon as
the majority comes back we basically
sends we wait for the true time to pass
and then respond back that this voice
for now in the multi split right what we
have here is like a scenario where a do
a read on the key 100 and then I do a
right to key 100 300 and 400 for the
values a b c respectively and so what i
do here again we do with a split li a
plus little lock lookup so we have a
couple of splitters in this case i have
the split leader and so in a and split 0
which gives me my data for the row with
the key 100 and it requires a read lock
then we do the lookups for the other
keys where we want to write to we send
the commit request through the split
leaders and while we are doing this we
choose one coordinator for this
transaction who is basically the chef
for this transaction and we tag all
these splits fit leaders as part of this
transaction so now the first thing that
we do because we want to write to key
1/100 is we actually have to check if
you still have the read logon on 100 and
we have to elevate it to to a write lock
now if there's any conflicts any like
possibility of a deadlock what we do is
a wait and want so basically younger
transactions are border and restarted
orders and sections are the ones that
are succeeding so and once we have all
the the real quick said lock this is
basically the first phase of the
two-phase commit protocol we can push
like the data out to our split replicas
and acknowledge of course that we have
the locks assigned times them again
replicate to the other replicas of the
of the splits and then everybody is
coming back with the commit for this
transaction and once we have all the
commit transactions notifications we
wait out the true time times them and
then give the success transaction back
to the to the client all right I have
one minute left I don't know if I get
cut off in my audio when I run over so I
want to do a really quick demo because I
think it is actually fairly powerful so
let's see if I get that working so I did
do we need to do a couple of things
number one is
here I have a core fauna running and
what I'm using here just to explain it
in very simple terms as I use the ycs be
workload and see if you need to fix
something here generate some data so
what I have is I have in kubernetes I
have some clients running which you see
why CSB schema of like user table and
I'm gonna write through these user
tables so let's do demo 3 and then I
also do demo 4 so what this is doing
here is nothing else and I sending a
pops up message actually which my
clients are listening to and they can't
get instructions through this pops up
message and the pops up message here
says I want to do a random reads with a
target of 50 per client and I want to do
random stale reads with a target of 50
per client I'm running that towards
against two different instances I want
to show you the power of a bounded reads
so one thing that we also see is like if
you sometimes see even a read-only
transaction but a read-only strong con
transaction if it conflicts with your
write it could sometimes like end up
slow so if you have the possibility to
do time bounded queries where you allow
a little bit of staleness even if it's
like less than a second or a second of
staleness if you can accommodate that in
your application do this because those
speed up your queries tremendously and
helps basically with lock contention if
you see things like that so what do we
have here
let me update this let's see if crow
fauna is still happy with me it looks
like it's heavy
happy so we see here right now it's
starting to run so this was an occult
instance that hasn't done much like for
hours basically and I just started this
workload and then what you can see here
is basically I have clients in Asia in
Europe and in the United States which
are sending requests write requests
against the database so you can see here
in the US it's 33 milliseconds in Asia
on a
round-trip time and in Europe is 88 so
this is just single cell rights right so
this is a little basically law of
physics latency these are strong reads
so I always have to check against the
leader of that split if I have the
latest data now if I do time bounded you
see there is not much difference here
the reason here is this is actually in
the US that instance right it doesn't
have replicas globally it just have
basically multi-region us so you still
have to go to the s to get your data if
you look at the latency it's from Asia
or from Europe now let me show what that
means if you actually use a multi
regional global database here in this
case and I want to zoom in to actually
show you this a little bit nicer so what
do we have here here I have a global
database where have read-only
replicas in Asia and in Europe so you
see that the times for reading strong is
still about the same it's a little lower
as you can see so you sometimes you just
don't need to do move any data you need
just to check if you still have the
latest data and then you do the random
read so 10 milliseconds from Asia
hundred sixty-six from Europe about 100
but then we go down here and as you can
see here I do time bounded and they are
all about nine milliseconds so that is
the power of time of time power that
reads with cloud spanner all right
moving to the related sessions just two
things that I want to point out tomorrow
today at 3:30 and then tomorrow at 10:20
there are two more sessions on spanner
really interesting the first one is for
under fights the VP of engineering and
then the second one is showing how
Google Cloud Storage is actually built
the metadata service is built on top of
cloud spanner and what what qualities
gives that to you and with that there
are a couple of resources your the best
one is cloud that google.com slash
spanner gives you basically an entry
point into everything if you want to
learn a little bit about optimizations I
have a video series under till about
cloud spanner so today I think I learned
about
Spiner what you can see here basically
and then last but not least please
please rate this session if you liked it
if you didn't like it if you want to see
something else
every feedback is welcome but be nice
and constructive please and with that
thank you very much for joining and have
a great day
[Applause]
[Music]